Gooood morning, gamers!
Surprise, surprise, another Minecraft episode.
That's right, everyone!
"What- what?!?"
"Is it complete?"
"Is the giant meatball complete?"
No.
It's not fully done yet.
But, once the giant meatball is finally rebuilt, there will be no more suffering and pain in this world.
Isn't that right, Joergen?
So, ends this serie- *chuckles*
Hey!
What are you doing on my property?! Get out!
Wow, that's so weird they just disape- AAH!
Wha- I didn't do anything!!
He hacked your brain!
*Laughing* Look at this dude just staring at a blank wall.
Hey, Sven!
Sven!
*bruh snd efx#1*
Oh hey, Sven. How are you doin'?
We got stuff to do, today. Come on, gamer, let's go.
Where are my boys at?
Where are my gamer boys at?
I gotta show you guys something really, really epic.
That I didn't realise until last episode.
Alright, boy, get in.
Get in.
God damn it.
Alright, boy, get in.
This is - *chuckles*
Ah- Sven!
*sigh* Wait- Do I have a spare one?
I do, okay.
Sven, wait up!
Sven, please! Stop!
(Subtitle by *I am HeRe *in description at bottom)(watch my videos)
There you are.
My dude.
People keep commenting how Sven has survived like five- six creeper explosions.
Oh, wait, there's another creeper.
Alright, just wait here, buddy.
I gotta show the bros.
Where was it..?
Ahh!
Yeah, here we go.
So, I got- Uh, where is it?
This one! And I was like, "Oh, that's not that good,"
But, as you can see, it has fortune 3 on it. So, now, whenever I mine a diamond..
..It drops two!!
*wow :0*
Two diamonds?!
Almost everytime!
Sven! C'mere, you have to see this.
Why did no one tell me this?
I mean you DID tell me.
Dude, we're gonna be rich! Sven, we're gonna-
Sven!
Okay, sometimes it drops one. But, MOST of the time it drops two.
This is crazy! Look two! Look two! Look- Sven, we're rich!
Look, NINETEEN diamonds out of that? Okay! Okay!
Oh, dude, we could start a diamond business!
Hey, can you sell diamonds in Minecraft? *chuckles*
Alright, Sven get in.
'Said get in.
Did I say not get in or did i say get in.
NO!
RUN, SVEN!
*sighs in relief*
*sighs*
Sven dies, the series is over. Remember, gamers.
Remember.
Today we have a very, very, very important mission *it's that important*
That's why I got all these diamonds.
Sven, plea-
We stay here.
Gamers stay here.
Damn, I can't believe how rich I am.
Look at this. LOOK AT THIS DUDE!
Look at this dude!
Alright, I can officially not even stack them like this
What do I want to make? I'm fully enchanted, right? What do I wa-
I don't know what to make, I got everything I want
I got this weird little baby
*very cute babby yes*
It doesn't-
It doesn't do anything. Stupid baby...
Sven, I'm not gonna lie, I lowkey kinda miss...
Having water sheep around
*a soul for a soul*
I know it's- It's good that he's gone *chuckles*